je me présente leona rosenberg escroc
professionnel
voici ma nouvelle victime soit celui
6103 une nouvelle excuse aime moi j'ai
sursauté de faire votre connaissance
elle possède sans le savoir une oeuvre
d'une valeur inestimable qui appartenait
à ma grand mère je ne vendrai pour rien
au monde ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
d'une héroïne qui fait souffler un vent
d'optimisme notre à gérer c'est votre
cas non ils n'ont rien du tout c'est
nous
c'est une star elle fait le buzz nous
retrouvons ce matin car les twins tuto
rapide de paris on a dansé niveau
[Musique]
le sentiment d'une rencontre que c'est
sûr vous êtes quelqu'un de confiance et
d'emplacements à la légère
[Musique]
gêné par pitié ne vous fiez pas aux
apparences
[Musique]
l'usurpateur êtes un grand malade 1 vous
m'avez foutu dans la merde jusqu'au cou
c'est une femme et faites moi confiance
vous allez en reste
ah non ça va je donnais les colons les
le long des gaines l'épilation tout ça
dans l'eau excusez moi je vais leur
mettre ma carrière